now you get the sense that when director
Comey entered the FBI building it became
like the Wardrobe in that famous CS
Lewis book his own fantasy land with
rules that didn't apply to mere mortals
well today the supercilious pious
sanctimonious former FBI director Jim
Comey was roasted the Inspector General
found that he was in clear violation of
Department of Justice guidelines and his
sworn duty in handling information
related to the dealings his dealings
with the president and the dossier
now commis conduct was an affront to the
standards expected of all DOJ employees
and it's a stain on the long proud
history of the FBI but tonight here's
what you need to understand call me
along with clapper Brennan struck and
McCabe and perhaps others fancied
themselves as Trump resisting
superheroes self-appointed saviours of
truth justice and the American Way well
deep state actors they look the other
way as Comey abused his position all the
privileges and power of the FBI and a
planned effort to destroy the man he had
utter disdain for Donald Trump now Comey
comes from the rarified upper crust of
elite Washington lawyers to them Trump
from the outset was an uncouth real
estate mogul turned reality star the
antithesis of what many of these self
anointed elites wanted in their
president now folks like Comey
themselves have coasted for years on
their pedigree and puffery they don't
like disruptors because people like
Trump they're going to pull back the
curtain on the status quo the old guard
the establishment they don't like that
one bit the IG report tells us that call
me meticulously planned exactly how he
would inform president elect Trump of
the salacious details
that steel dossier he colluded with
McCabe the FBI general counsel and
others in advance to plan their strategy
to set up the president-elect so after
briefing Trump about the dossier at
Trump Tower Comey started drafting a
memo to memorialize the encounter during
a car ride back to the office was all
planned out then a day later on January
11th
CNN reported this that the intelligence
Chiefs intelligence chiefs of the United
States when they briefed President Obama
Thursday and president-elect Trump on
Friday they believed that the source of
the dossier was credible and his sources
were credible and they believed that a
the president elected the president
should know that the Russians were
claiming they had compromising
information on him that's just
disgraceful
well that opened of course the media
floodgates and a wave of damaging and
totally fraudulent fake news stories
followed about the phony Clinton
financed steel dossier now in the months
that followed Comey memorialized his
other meetings with the president
several me several memos were sent to
his personal lawyer Daniel Richmond who
then at commis behest shared the
contents of at least two of them with
the news media why to spark the
appointment of a special counsel to
investigate possible trump Russia
collusion but the president smelled a
rat he confronted and ultimately fired
call me over the leaks to the media
which of course Comey vociferous Lee
denied I don't consider what I did with
mr. Richmond a leak I told him about an
unclassified conversation with the
president one month after firing Comey
and in reaction to the now former FBI
directors Capitol Hill testimony Trump
in a tweet wrote despite so many false
statements and lies total and complete
vindication and Wow Comey
is a leaker so it's Trump right we're
regarding the leaking maybe Comey never
considered releasing his own memos
leaking because his ultimate goal
bringing down the president was no
bull he saw it as he was carrying out
his civic duty I intentionally gave this
information to a friend intending that
it be out in the media
I wanted it together in the media right
as a private citizen I could do that and
did that actually Jim you weren't
supposed to do that this is from page 61
of the IG report Comey had several other
lawful options available to him to
advocate for the appointment of a
special counsel which he told us was his
goal in making the disclosure what was
not permitted was the unauthorized
disclosure of sensitive information
investigative information obtained
during the course of FBI employment in
order to achieve a personally desired
outcome so he leaked and lied to the
public about it then there is the
question of how many memos Comey shared
with his pal Richmond for media
distribution and whether they contain
classified material now in repeated
interviews call me said versions of this
I sent mr. Richmond a copy of a two-page
unclassified memo and asked him to get
the substance of it out to the media you
personally gave him nothing else ever I
sent one memo unclassified then still
unclassified and it's recounted in my
book the book but the IG says on page 51
of the report Richmond volunteered to
the bureau and his interview that if
you're collecting the one you should get
the other three memos Richmond had
received from Comey whoops adding there
could be classified information
contained in what Richmond received from
Comey that is a key part of this this
this report could be classified
information so repeatedly Kerr repeated
liar and in his interview with Bret
Baier last year he made this ludicrous
claim FBI protocol says your own
employment agreement with the FBI
prohibits quote the unauthorized
disclosure of any information or
material from or related to FBI files or
any information acquired by virtue of my
official employment without prior
written permission from the FBI did you
have
written permission no and I didn't
consider it part of an FBI file all the
things I talked about with you as an FBI
director he was a work product no it was
not it was my personal president first
of all any man who says aid to memoir is
someone you should never trust okay that
is just the IG on page 52 says commis
characterization of the memos as
personal records finds no support in the
law and is wholly incompatible with the
plain language of the statutes
regulations and policies defining
federal records and the terms of commis
FBI employment agreement so he's not
just a leaker and the liar he's
incompetent or perhaps willfully
ignorant neither of those is good either
still after all this Comey had the goal
this morning to tweet DOJ IG found no
evidence that call me or his attorneys
released any of the classified
information contained in any of the
memos to members of the media I don't
need a public apology from those who
defame me but a quick message with a
sorry we lied about you would be nice
sorry Jimmy don't hold your breath the
IG report established beyond a shadow of
a doubt that Comey engaged in a grand
personal vendetta against this president
and in doing so he abused his authority
and while Comey must be breathing easier
tonight given the AG's decision not to
prosecute him for this leaking he's not
out of the woods yet the IG report on
the FBI Russian probe and the use of
those FISA warrants is forthcoming and
it was Comey who signed the first FISA
warrant to spy on American citizens now
based on the dossier he knew or should
have known was not credible that was
filed with the FISA Court big no-no but
if Comey manages to escape prosecution
for conduct that his underlings would be
charged for then the damage he did to
the FBI will extend to our belief in the
treasured words carved into this
preme court building equal justice under
the law and that's the angle